Santoya Brown long is breaking her
silence now that her new memoir is out
she says she was a victim of sex
trafficking when she was arrested at the
age of 16 for robbing and killing a man
she says pick her up for sex she
believed he was going to kill her
she was sentenced to life in prison but
her sentence was commuted by Tennessee's
Governor Bill Haslam after she served 15
years I interviewed some Toya last night
so what's the message for people that
find themselves or that are in the
situation that you're in right now I
want you to know that you know there are
people who see you who hear you there
are people in society they tell you that
you're not worth anything that they
can't place value on your life
they can't assign that to you she's made
it her life mission now to help young
people who are incarcerated I have a
longer interview on CBS then that will
air all throughout the day but what was
really moving is number one she's got a
new memoir out where she talks about
what it was like she didn't realize that
she was a victim of sex trafficking
until she was almost in her thirties
she's gotten a lot of support and
sympathy I'm very curious to see your
interview yeah it's really and she also
tells us she's willing to meet with the
family she acknowledges there's another
victim Johnny Allen so she's really to
meet with that family